So for me my school was quite good at tech. I was fortunate enough to go to a girls school so
there wasn't any kind of oh you can't do this because you're a girl because we all were.
So they were very bored with the tech thing. We got to go to a lot of different competitions,
sometimes at unis we got to see what computer science was like for them. I think tech's just
exciting because for me a lot of the problem-solving aspects and also the job I could have in the future
might not even exist yet. Like it's probably for something that's not even around which is quite
exciting I think. I don't know just how fast-paced tech is and how much it changes. Kind of like what
Charlotte said you don't know what job you could have in the future and everything you can do there's
so many different routes if you want to be creative, if you want to go down a science or a research route
it's really a degree which gives you so many opportunities to do different things and just
means you have so many paths open while also having a plan and being at the forefront of what
is going to happen later in the world.
What Grace just said about being creative for years I thought I'd be doing an English Lit degree
so it's been a bit of a change but I just when I started getting in learning about tech in my school
which is also an all-girls school so I really encouraged it and when I started learning I just
loved how every single aspect of tech is so logical because it has to be but in the same way so counterintuitive.
And I loved that kind of studying that and then learning how to be creative within that those
restrictions and learning how to work around them and work with them just found that really interesting.
I chose to pursue a career in tech because unlike you guys I wasn't in a school but I didn't see it as
knock or anything I just thought it's you know it's really it's deemed quite an intelligent thing to
study and I was quite good at like maths and I quite like problem solving. I quite like the fact you can
get something tangible with programming for example and I thought it was really interesting.
I actually didn't intend to end up in tech at all I didn't study anything tech based I was very much
kind of writing and creative in that sense but I think part of the reason of that for me personally
was when I went to school that there wasn't so much representation for women in computer science I mean
I don't think that we actually did computer science we just did an IT bracket or there wasn't much
representation there wasn't much encouragement from my teachers to pursue that so it was never really
anything that I ever saw myself being involved with so I completely fell into it by chance and love it
and I'm really happy to be here but yeah I sometimes yeah think what it would have been like to
study from a younger age but is it like is it still like that um is there much more representation now
obviously just finishing the degree? To be honest like I think anyone who any girls who are in the
computer science kind of studying it right now will know for a fact that if if you've got boys in
your classes and you're not in an all-girls school it will be very heavily male dominated because that
doesn't mean you can't do well that you can't get to the same places and I personally don't think
I've been treated any differently worse or to be honest I feel like I've been treated better than I
am a girl in tech because it's so uncommon I think now is a great time to get involved in tech because
especially so many opportunities for getting women involved like scholarships and sponsorships etc
yeah it's definitely improving going from school to university was a big jump the general ratios in
the classes but I'm really lucky to have a woman in computer science society at university which
probably wasn't that a few years ago um and you definitely feel like everyone has an equal opportunity
and you're represented in your lecturers and
I know yeah it's suddenly um it's very obvious in my lectures that my courses um like women are a
minority in it but we're split into tutor groups and I'm lucky enough that four out of seven in my
tutor group are women so I don't feel isolated or um like there's no one I can talk to obviously
everyone's very friendly as well so um there hasn't been any feeling of division but it's nice that it
feels like if I felt there was I there are people I could turn to for me like the numbers aren't really
there I mean they kind of are but in my tutor group probably a fifth of us are women and I've not spoken
to any of the other women in my group because they're not in my like smaller group but I think it doesn't
mean I'm treated any differently just because I am like one of the few in the group so yeah